all I did was go home and eat and train
and eat and train because I didn't want
to look like your kid think you could
handle it whether they're learning a new
skill for a role or pushing their body
to its absolute extremes there is no end
to the things these actors will do for
their craft number one Parenthood is
never easy yet Penn Badgley faced
different problems than most when he
became a father around the same time as
his fictional counterpart on you Badgley
admitted that in some ways sharing this
experience with Joe made things harder
because he could identify with his fear
but described Joe's approach to
fatherhood as morbid whereas he was
having such a light and joyful
experience number 2. Lupita Nyong'o has
a fear of water I panic swim like a
puppy but she needed to look confident
underwater for black panther wakanda
forever and so Nyong'o trained alongside
Olympic level swimmers sometimes even
performing bear crawls across the bottom
of the pool holding 20 pound weights in
either hand I felt so powerful doing
that number three Tom Holland is no
stranger to stunts and yet the
webslinger seems to have met his match
filming for Uncharted which would
sometimes have Holland attached to a
spinning box roughly 100 feet in the air
he may have walked away with a few
bruises but seems to stay positive it
was fun it was a lot of fun and the
stunts is something I've always really
enjoyed number four we're glad she
didn't go through this alone Rue's
intervention on season 2 episode 5 of
euphoria was especially emotional for
Zendaya saying I mean I beat myself up I
still have some scars on my legs and got
quite a few bruises she was grateful to
have her co-stars checking in with her
between takes because obviously it's
like a war zone number five it's
important to check on your loved ones
when Michael B Jordan was filming black
panther he actively withdrew from
friends and family to better understand
killmonger's loneliness this continued
to affect his mental health long after
film though he's spoken about how
therapy has helped him but just
readjusting to being around the people
that care about me number six Brendan
Frazier is back the whale is his first
major Motion Picture in years and in
order to portray this 600 pound Charlie
he underwent a makeup transformation
that forced him to become completely
re-familiar with his body as he stated I
needed to learn to absolutely move in a
new way I developed muscles I did not
know that I had I even felt a sense of
vertigo at the end of the day when all
the appliances were removed number seven
we've all faced self-doubt Dakota
Johnson underwent over a year of
strength and ballet training for her
role in Suspiria but what she struggled
with most was her confidence only four
days before filming Johnson had what she
described as a meltdown in the
director's office forcing him and
co-star Tilda Swinton to try and
convince her that she was right for the
role number eight Lady Gaga lost herself
in this role she's stated that she truly
lived as Patricia for a year and a half
while filming House of Gucci and that
she didn't break her Italian accent for
nine months in an interview with Vogue
Gaga revealed that she had some
psychological difficulty near the end
especially recalling one day when she
took a walk through Italy and as she
described it I panicked I thought I was
on a movie set number 9. Alex Wolff is
willing to take things too far for the
scene in hereditary where his character
breaks his nose wolf offered to actually
do it hey I'll do it on a real desk
director ariaster arranged for a
cushioned desk instead but wolf still
managed to injure his leg jumping up
he's since gone on to admit that he's
lost sleep on account of the role
stating that movie did about as much
damage to me as a movie can do number
10. you've never seen a movie like this
before for top gun Maverick Tom Cruise
underwent a special training program
condensing two years of Flight Training
into three months he learned special
breathing techniques from real Top Gun
Pilots because Cruz was actually
battling against GeForce adding 1600
pounds of pressure onto him it must be
very difficult to act while trying to
avoid getting sick or passing out number
11. can you become a professional tennis
player overnight Emma Stone had hardly
even played tennis before being cast in
battle of the sexes and it took her
months to get it right Stone said that
learning how to do a serve or backhand
like Billie Jean was more of an
Impossible Dream than a reality but she
studied videos of King's matches and
worked with a personal trainer to gain
15 pounds in muscle number 12. if you're
playing Steve Jobs you've gotta walk the
walk Ashton Kutcher spent three months
trying to perfect Steve Jobs's unique
style of walking for the movie jobs
something the entrepreneur attributes to
the fact that he's regularly Barefoot
Kutcher also read read all of jobs
favorite books and listen to his
favorite music but he still describes
portraying jobs as the most terrifying
thing I have done in my life number 13
Natalie Portman literally thought she
would end filming Black Swan she was
trained like an actual ballerina losing
toenails dislocating a rib and even
suffering a concussion in the process
she lost around 20 pounds and endured
work days that could last up to 16 hours
sometimes on a diet of little more than
almonds and carrots number 14. Leonardo
DiCaprio definitely earned his Oscar in
preparing for the Revenant he slept
inside animal carcasses submerged
himself in freezing Waters and ate raw
bison liver despite being vegan he
walked away from the experience with a
greater appreciation for what
Frontiersman went through I don't know
how these men did it number 15 Jared
Leto is known for his method acting
portraying Dr morbius Leto would move
about the entire set on crutches and yet
this wasn't even his greatest challenge
when taking on the role according to him
he was surprised by how much he related
to the character explaining that he's
not used to playing roles that are a
little bit closer to who I am number 16
you don't want to mess with Charlize
Theron she did 95 of her own stunts for
the 2017 action thriller Atomic blonde
requiring strict and intensive physical
training at one point she even clenched
her jaw so tight during training that
she cracked two of her back teeth bad
enough to require dental surgery number
17 she was on top of the world and
couldn't even enjoy it Anne Hathaway
lost 25 pounds in only two weeks for her
role in Les Miserables and although her
performance would win her the Oscar
she's admitted that she couldn't really
enjoy the moment due to the severe
depression her weight loss had brought
on number 18 you do not want to try to
emu late Zac Efron's Baywatch body as
hard as he worked for it Ephron would
eventually struggle with severe
depression and insomnia that his doctors
associated with his Extreme Weight Loss
Ephron has spoken about keeping a better
balance with food and how he prefers to
maintain an extra two to three percent
body fat number 19. how much of your day
would you sacrifice for Jake Gyllenhaal
the answer is all of it he adopted a
nocturnal lifestyle for his role in
Nightcrawler he'd eat as little as
possible losing 30 pounds as a result
and would even catch rides with on-duty
Paparazzi looking back on the experience
Gyllenhaal would later state it takes a
bit of time to shake it off but
concluded in the end it's just acting
number 20. Christian Bale put his body
through extremes for his role in The
Machinist he lived on a diet of only 200
calories a day often consisting of only
black coffee an apple and a can of tuna
he lost around 62 pounds but before
immediately bulking up for his
subsequent role in Batman bill has said
that he'd never do that again as he
feels he's getting older and in his
words I'd prefer not to die some of
these actors may have gotten a bit more
than they were expecting with these
roles but there's no denying their
passion and dedication which grueling
film experience were you most surprised
by